99% of the Isis and al-qaeda content
that we take down on Facebook are AI
systems flag before any human sees it
Mark Zuckerberg may have said all the
right things this week in his testimony
about Facebook's push to eradicate
terrorist content from its platform but
the counterterrorism community says it's
not true
Facebook is failing when it comes to
combating terrorism we're not actually
seeing that translate into the reduction
of terrorist content on these platforms
we're not actually seeing Isis bomb
making videos permanently removed and
Congress is piling on one lawmaker
citing two instances from the past ten
days alone the Isis content was
discovered on Facebook which included an
execution video March 29th on April 9th
there were five pages located on April
9th of Hezbollah content a big part of
the problem according to terrorism
experts is that Facebook officials are
still relying on its users to report
terrorist activity and content when they
should be policing the platform
themselves on the scale that they have
now they can't just sit back and let
users report problematic content if
you're using that as a standard you're
never gonna even make a small blip on
the radar screen in terms of what's
happening on these platforms other
experts caution that Facebook may never
get this problem fully under control
you're talking about massive massive
amounts of data even more than the Intel
community normally deals with on a
day-to-day basis it's a Herculean task
to think that they're going to be able
to cull through all that information and
find the bad guys other than the ones
who are really really obvious about it
Zuckerberg told lawmakers today a new
beefed up counterterrorism team of 200
people inside Facebook is the answer but
the real holy grail for Facebook and
other social media companies when it
comes to controlling access to their
platforms is more advanced artificial
intelligence something Zuckerberg says
is currently in development